gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen Rohan
Kevin yet whoosh Kili
you guys are just a slice of the
promiscuous Carnival of souls that are
hanging out here at Burning Man I'd like
to engage you with the following inquiry
okay what is the meaning of life what
are we meant to do with ourselves what
is our noble aim what is our holy
purpose the end scene of the film flight
from death a quest for immortality has a
line by jean-paul sartre it says
everything has been figured out except
how to live and then he goes on to say
so perhaps the better question is not
what are we to do with death but what
are we to do with life life exists in
individual moments and it is up to us to
make sure that those moments are vital
interconnected and grand to make a
masterpiece out of life one that we
would willingly live again and again for
all of eternity
and this is what we can strive for you
hear a line like that and it's really
poetic because it's basically saying
that we don't control what brought us
into being we don't control the
circumstances the miracles within
miracles within miracles within miracles
that led to the DNA and your father's
sperm landing at the egg of your mom and
the conception and etc etc and so the
film is ultimately saying there's so
much that we don't control except so
there's always we don't control so what
do we do and it ends with this notion
that that becomes the challenge
everything has been figured out the laws
of physics so on and so forth except
this thing of like what to do with us
you know the existential conundrum is
what the [ __ ] do we do and of course in
the face of finitude immortality it's
like yeah you know we worry about this
thing called death and they're
ultimately saying well don't worry about
death and instead focus on individual
moments you know and make those moments
vital interconnected grand holy make a
masterpiece out of your life willingly
that well you would willingly live again
and again for all of eternity and
finally he says you don't conquer the
anxiety about dying you read it with
which is a beautiful ending again in the
face of our cosmic hopelessness but I
I'm less interested in the cosmic
hopelessness and more interested in
moments of such sublime beauty rapture
and Rhapsody that they push death out of
our minds long enough for us to forget
that it exists and for that moment we
experience infinitude we become as gods
we remember who we are we remember what
we forgot we are an animating force in
the universe we too we do take matter of
low organization right we put it through
our mental filters and we extrude
technological super structures right
we're the coral reef like animal the
extruder technological material that
turns that farts that vomits iphones
computers the internet and space
shuttles into existence and the ironic
thing is if you zoom out far enough
right it does look like we instantiate
our imagination David Deutsch said in
the beginning of infinity that if you
look at the topography of a modern city
that's a physical topography where the
forces of mind intentionality economics
again consciousness itself has trumped
geology but why does it take time-lapse
photography why does it take us zooming
out why does it take a shift in scale
and in time in order for us to
appreciate what we are right this X
tropic evolutionary force this sentient
emergence this Technium so to speak this
super organism that in a way is the most
heroic thing in the cosmos because we
are a runaway train against entropy
right we are on a holy pathway towards
the Omega Point right supersymmetry
hyper intelligence right the whatever
mckenna calls it the transcendental
object at the end of time beckoning us
towards trans sentience so that we can
realize that we are infinite and so what
do we do to remind ourselves of this
what do we do to purge ourselves of our
amnesia how do we trigger how do we
occasion what Jaime wheel calls em
nemesis the forgetting of the forgetting
how do we remember who we are
I think cinema does it well I think
editing does it well I think steering
attention towards the big picture does
it well I think OPA today Jason C
doesn't well I think occasional
experiences of awe rapture and beauty
experiences the stretcher mental models
of the world once a mind is stretched by
a new idea
we'll never return to its original
position what is ah what do positive
psychologists tell us about experiences
of OPA today Jason Co and wonder they
tell us that they are cognitive
cognitively beneficial how so how is
getting gobsmacked by beauty how is
being delighted and surprised and hurled
into an ecstatic no-man's land of
cognitive thrills good for us well it
stretches our mental models of reality
what is ah ah is an experience of such
perceptual vastness that your mental
models of reality that you rely upon
right the map instead of the territory
that you rely upon to orient yourself in
the world the set of algorithms that
allow you to function adequately in the
world and not be perpetually astonished
right the filters through which you make
sense of the matrix those things are
called not just into question but they
are invited to enlarge themselves your
models of the world have to now
accommodate themselves to this new
transcendental object at the end of time
and when you come to a place like this
it's basically a theater of the absurd
that invites you into that contemplation
with the transcendental object at the
end of time this place is unconstructed
dream space this place is a supermarket
of memes this place is a juxtaposition
of pocket universes this place is a
demolition derby of reality constructs
colliding on a parched void the effect
of which is the collision between mind
and such enrapturing novelty that you
get hurled into ecstatic mind spaces
that are so novel and so new that it
heals you of your fractures somehow it
does that the dance with the ecstatic
cleanses us of our suffering it's an
absolution last night I had a
church-like experience and I don't even
go to church you know the secular Jew
called me had an ecstatic encounter with
a shamanic mobile church called Mayan
warrior in this mobile church art car
started moving through the playa in
pursuit of whatever art piece they were
gonna park themselves on and set up set
up the show for the night and the the
bicyclists following the art car in
pilgrimage through the parched void was
the most
sniffing display of the word Church
italicized back to its real meaning you
know that I've ever witnessed like it
brings me almost to tears to to to to to
try to fit it in my head [ __ ] act of
reverence so that's been burning man so
far what do you think Kevin leadership
can imagine back in the days the
military falling the general thousands
of soldiers falling the feeling of
meaning that people used to get when
they go to battle when you're so caught
up in the meaning of something larger
than yourself if you forget yourself and
you lose your ego and you have what they
call ecstatic corny toss they wrote
about it and stealing fire and the
moment of ecstatic of money tasks is
where you're connecting with something
larger than ourselves it's the reason
why I mean I know we don't like war here
but it's the reason that somebody would
willingly serve in a war and be willing
to die for an idea that they believe in
the idea can be corrupted no doubt but
it's what makes us submit to something
larger than ourselves that heals us of
the diseases of self obsession of the
ego you nailed it it comes from the
inside come has to come to come from the
inside how did you summon up the courage
to serve in battle it's that's not
carriage or you're boring you're born
with it you just you either have it or
you don't
yeah you have to trigger that opens it
and like you have it with this some
people are just they're more susceptible
to shamanic trance right exactly they
can easy there it's easier for them to
submit because they don't have such
strong egos for instance yesterday where
we were at area where the meditation we
couldn't submit to that like they
submitted okay so you have your own set
of triggers well that's been an
eight-minute tirade we have an audience
promiscuous souls surfing the playa
what's up guys thank you for joining our
hands I speak what I feel if I hold it
in that makes me kind of antsy
I have to purge I want you to tell me
about a transitory enchanted moment in
which you held your breasts and you were
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation you neither understood nor
desired face to face perhaps for the
last time in history but something can
measure it to your capacity for wonder
if there's one place you can give an
answer to that question that's Burning
Man but it's hard to pick just any one
moment because there's so many but I
would like to add to what you said
earlier then the magic of Burning Man
exists primarily because it's temporary
it's ephemeral it's it's impermanent and
at the end of these seven days this
whole city disappears all the art is
burnt and it's gone that's because you
think that the minute something stops
being impermanent we start taking it for
granted things are only holy when
they're outside of time and in stasis
and so ephemerality by definition is a
subjectivity that exists outside of time
if you can enjoy ephemerality without
being haunted and depressed you're
actually in the moment it's when you
start thinking oh [ __ ] this moment is
gonna end that you're not really in the
moment anymore
you're anticipating misery which I'm
pretty good at yep but it's interesting
this place has been very much a place
that finally does justice to a lot of
quotes that have been like post-it notes
that I've been collecting for what I
think transcendence should be like you
know like I'm a like a religious
pilgrimage no religion right what does
they call it as spirituality Wayne's
experience is the new faith and we are
refugees from the mundane right we are
refugees from the mundane and so okay
that makes sense this was from an
article called the death of aw in the
Age of Awesome and and and he starts
with an F scott Fitzgerald line and it's
talking about Dutch sailors so imagine
like you know after Christopher Columbus
or whatever Europeans going to what they
perceived as the new world for the first
time right from their POV it's an
intergalactic journey right they're
sailing out into the void and their land
a world in which they have no reference
points so f scott Fitzgerald wrote about
its potential specifically the Dutch
sailors and he talks about them
witnessing the fresh green breasts of a
new world okay and then he says man must
have held his breath right in the
presence of this new continent right
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation okay compelled by you
don't have a choice compelled into an
aesthetic contemplation he neither
understood nor desired and they says
face to face for the perhaps for the
last time in history with something can
measure it to his capacity for wonder
because think about it once we map the
planet been there done that the map
becomes the territory and then note
nothing ever fits are nothing as ever
kamesha it to our capacity forward so I
read that quote and it made me mad
because I'm like I want that [ __ ]
feeling I want the feeling of those
European sailors seeing the new world
for the first time I'm not endorsing
what they did with the natives
afterwards I'm just talking about that
first feeling of that virginal noticing
that sends the first sight unencumbered
by knowing this I would read that quote
and I was like but he said for the last
time in history so unless we go to outer
space we don't get to experience that
Burning Man
by being such a brilliant assemblage of
reality constructs you know Eric Davis's
demolition-derby of reality constructs
colliding into parts void forces you gob
smacks you you - I think experiencing
something finally
kamesh your capacity for wonder and as
Carl Sagan the eminent wonder junkie
astronomer used to say I mean it is in
the act of wonder that we get off with
God right and that's [ __ ] awesome
right yeah like yeah I was gonna say
something really vulgar and spiritual
but I thought maybe I'll hold it you
guys can guess maybe anyway thank you
guys for hanging
[Music]
statue behind them other people over
there wow-wow-wow
we'll come back later good afternoon
good evening and good night